so one of the best ways to get more
views on your videos is by doing smart
youtube keyword research by doing this
you can come up with powerful video
ideas and get your videos to ultimately
rank in search so you can get views 24 7
365. so in this video i'm joined by rob
from vidiq and we're going to be going
through
three
quick tips to help you get started with
keyword research with some free tools as
well as diving into some of the advanced
tools and ways to get even more keyword
research insights using vid iq so buckle
your seat belt because this is the
coffee with kennel show and it's coming
up right now three two one
[Music]
welcome to the coffee with kennel show
my name is sean cannell and i'm super
fired up for today's episode with rob
wilson from vid iq who is a youtube
creator himself
who is a keyword research expert and is
really has a lot of powerful insights in
helping us understand how to use these
strategies to grow our youtube channels
during the first part of coffee with
kennel if you're new to the show we have
about a 30 minute training for you and
then during the second part we welcome
guests onto the show and we're actually
going to be diving into your topics your
channels and doing some keyword research
for you um and there's going to be a lot
to learn during the entire thing so if
you haven't smashed the like button give
us a like let me know where you're
watching from and rob welcome to coffee
with kennel how's it going hey sean uh
it's going excellently thank you very
much for for me inviting me on to
another one of your shows and
i've decided that from now on whenever
i'm on uh think media uh content i'm
gonna call your community the think
media rights i i think i established
that last time i was on are you okay
with that the think media writes
absolutely i mean it kind of reminds me
of bruce willis armageddon like we have
you know like the myself the think media
team and our friends like you are just
coming with that fire to destroy planets
okay well uh before we use the infinity
stones wrong i think we should uh
dive right into uh the content today and
i'm super fired up because you've got
before we get into some deeper dive
tools um with vid iq there's some basics
for getting started in keyword research
but here's a big question for you
is keyword research still relevant
because some people are kind of feels
like they're throwing out the baby with
the bath water when it comes to search
based content seo keyword research
what's your hot take on that
so i think my
um
short answer would be
yes keyword research is still
very important
but more and more caveats are being
added to that question as time goes by i
think ultimately for any creator
understanding what i call your keyword
universe or the the common tongue
of your video topic is crucial for
generating video ideas and then also
understanding how to title your content
in a very basic fashion
what's on the thumbnail what's in the
description video tags yes but also
more and more importantly you know what
you're actually saying in your videos
and you know what's appearing on screen
and there's some really exciting
things that youtube have been really
teasing as people
search and interact with youtube when
they're trying to you know find answers
to questions
and if someone's new to the term keyword
research what are we talking about like
what is a keyword and what is the goal
of keyword research
so if i was to give you a basic example
of this it might be something along the
lines of apple the tech company being a
very basic keyword but what sits
underneath that keyword and you've got
ipad you've got imac you've got iphone
what sits underneath that you've got
maybe the iphone pro
12
camera or the ipad ios 15
updates you know these keyword phrases
can get longer and longer and longer and
more specific and i think as
creators starting out on their youtube
journals they often find their niche of
a little corner of their youtube
universe by really becoming the expert
of the authority on something really
specific within
a keyword research area
yeah absolutely and that's where we get
the term long tail keywords because to
rank on youtube for apple
besides the fact that could be an apple
we eat or apple the company it's a
little vague it's not super specific
it's going to be highly competitive but
if we were to make a video called
best
telephoto
lens for the iphone
12
pro
max that's a pretty specific thing it's
actually something
under 50 yeah and i just because there
are some cheap ones on amazon i just was
checking out this brand called sandmark
on a recent trip for my iphone 12 max
and i was doing that exact search so
let's dive into a couple quick tips if
we just want to keep it super simple get
started right now um what are some tips
for getting started with keyword
research
yeah so
you know before we look at um any vid iq
tools the the i think the most powerful
tool to get you started
with understanding what people are
searching for on youtube is the youtube
search bar
and what it's going to do as soon as you
start to type in any
uh letters it's going to try and predict
what you're searching for as a viewer
and obviously as you're a viewer and
you're
adding more and more data to youtube in
terms of what you watch and your
preferences then those search terms are
going to become more and more aligned to
what you're interested in as a viewer
and as you're doing this research you
want to try and get into the mind of a
viewer themselves and what they're
searching for so i guess i've shown we
could probably just use that example uh
that we were talking about which is
apple maybe we'll go down to iphone as a
as a starting point and even when i just
type in iphone if i can spell it right
i'm not looking at my keyboard there we
go um we're getting all of the model
numbers and at the very top here is
iphone 13. now i iphone 13 as far as i'm
aware isn't even out yet so i'm guessing
already as somebody who may be
interested in this tech hmm are we
thinking about the release date are we
thinking about rumors are we thinking
about the price if i just type that in
we're already seeing you know launch
date release date unboxing the colors
rumors you know we let's let's go for
rumors and we'll see um what's added to
the um
keywords there's like there's a rumor
that there might be a fingerprint on the
i fingerprint scanner maybe uh also
touch id
is it gonna run at finally 120 hertz so
just by
typing in three i guess essential
keywords to create a keyword phrase we
have
15 potential ideas of what we might want
to create content on as a youtube
creator
that's super uh powerful and
my understanding is that those
predictions are in order of most popular
which doesn't surprise me
um that iphone 13 is probably one of the
hottest things right now people are
looking for the leaks and the rumors so
it's when you type in iphone if you go
all the way back you're sort of seeing
in sequence that iphone 13 is most
popular then people want to see content
related pro max 11 is still interesting
and of course we're going to dive in
deeper towards the
in this video later to actually see some
search volume and get more granular data
but at least from a like a quick hot
take level of what maybe should i talk
about next i can just start with the
youtube search bar
yeah and if you want to take that
a little bit further um i like to play a
very simple game with this search bar
which is the alphabet walkthrough we'll
we'll use again iphone 13 as a keyword
but all i'm going to do at this point is
simply go through the alphabet a single
character so we type in a
and look at all the v suggestions here
apple trailer apple event we've also got
the always on display that might be
interesting or something to look at as a
small channel focusing on a very
particular aspect of the tool but let's
try b and you have all the v suggestions
battery
bronze does that mean it's going to be a
bronze colored version of the iphone 13
that's interesting battery test all of
these suggestions as well and i could go
from a to z and you have dozens of
suggestions coming up so again really
good eye really good idea generator and
creating
very simple keywords that you can start
to write down as a you know
building up your
keyword universe that common tongue that
i was talking about in in the topic of
the iphone 13.
super powerful so so far we've covered
that definitely use the youtube search
bar and let me know in the comments do
you use the youtube search bar and use
that auto predict feature has that been
helpful have any of those ideas helped
you create a video idea that's done well
secondly do the alphabet walkthrough
what a cool tip take your topic and go
through a b c and you're looking for
remembering this is youtube giving you
insight and data into what real people
are searching you don't want to just
make videos necessarily in a fishbowl
where you're just with your own ideas
your question is what do people want to
see what are people interested in the
creator that understands the viewer best
wins
and this helps us do topic research
keyword research to do that but rob is
there any other tips in regards to
maybe even getting more insights using
the youtube search bar yeah you can turn
that alphabet walkthrough into simple
questions
and again
youtube search is now sophisticated
enough to comprehend what you're typing
out even if it doesn't make complete
sense so if i say iphone 13 when
now we're getting to this the the nuts
and bolts of really answering these
iphone 13 questions when's it coming out
when's the release date when's it going
to launch in a particular country we
could simply change that to how and then
we've got more
useful tips tricks and tutorial videos
that you could be making or thinking
about you know in a run-up to the launch
you know how many cameras is it going to
have how much is it going to cost
how do i charge it because we're still
not sure whether the iphone 13 is going
to have a charging cable uh another one
could be why
maybe not that one let's try um
was it when so we did when and we'll do
where i mean where's it coming out
it's it's gonna vary depending on the
keyword phrase that you're looking at
but you know the how the what the where
and the why uh there's always going to
be answers that need to questions that
need to be answered by
by youtube content and you could be
there to provide it
man that's some super valuable tips
right there think media community that
deserves a
you got to just press record
and i think uh if you
um
want to smash the like button we'd
appreciate it but those are some free
tools that you can use and you can get
started immediately coming up with some
great ideas but in just a second we're
going to be getting into
a little bit uh enhanced tools using vid
iq and this video is brought to you by
vidiq and right now you can check out
some details in the description down
below in order to uh get a free trial of
one of the paid plans because there's a
free version of it iq highly recommended
and you're going to see some of the
tools and things you can see there but
when you really go deep um this is a
suite of tools that will help you make
better data-driven decisions and come up
with the next best video to make and so
rob i'm super excited to get into this
and so um how can we now go even deeper
with keyword research using vid iq
yeah so uh sean i've done a couple of
searches here on youtube to um
just tease out some of some more data
uh that's going to be available for
different search terms and
i'm going to start off with a phrase
that now probably everybody is familiar
with uh nobody knew what youtube shorts
were a year ago and now today they're
according to youtube 15 billion
daily youtube shorts views which i still
can't quite comprehend but it's a
massively growing uh aspect of the
youtube platform and so maybe as a
creator i know sean you've done some um
videos on on youtube shots and i
certainly have um if we were doing a
search here how could we really drill
down into the particular topics that
people are interested in
in the bottom right hand corner we see
here the the keyword score from vidiq
this is a barometer this is just giving
you a general idea
of how many people are searching for a
particular keyword and also the
perceived competition from other
creators and you'll get this score quite
often in terms of a lot of search volume
but also a lot of competition because
there's many creators creating content
and different search topics get
saturated very very quickly so how do we
maybe drill down into this a little bit
more
one of the tools that we have here
on vid iq is called enable inline
keywords and what this is basically
going to do is open up the um the the
hood of a car and reveal
the
keywords that creators have used to
optimize their content and i'll use one
of our videos as an example we've tried
to really get to the
bottom of
what people will be searching for in
terms of youtube shorts it might be how
to make them it might be um
when are they coming out how do you make
thumbnails and so on and so forth and we
can click on any of these keywords
to launch what's called the keyword
inspector
and as we were talking about earlier
with the keyword score it's going to
show you all of the related keywords for
this topic that i've chosen which is
youtube shots
and we can see again that most of the
scores here are pretty competitive but
as i scroll down
i think i found one here potentially
sean this looks like a
a keyword
in a keyword of interest here with a
score of 72 over 100 which essentially
means
that
there's probably a bit of keyword search
volume there
and there's not as much competition as
as confirmed here and i think we know
this because
people have been looking forward to
youtube shops being monetized for about
six months now and finally very recently
youtube shorts have now become
monetizable and people are getting their
first paychecks after
all of that hard work that they've put
it been putting in the last two or three
months
so yeah look
well i love that you went inline
keywords and and then drilled down
clicking on a keyword took us inside of
it iq
um and
it also our intuition at least my
intuition at yours as well lines up with
that insight of we're looking for we
teach asq answer specific questions and
specific is a really key word it's not
just answer questions people want to
know generally about youtube's shorts
but now you discovered youtube shorts
monetization
so making a video specifically around
that topic and that um is of course
there's the shorts fun now
but even how where does monetization
come from shorts because it may not be
monetized in the shorts feed but if it's
watched on desktop and and so then now
we have the insight and i'm just hoping
to summarize this for everyone in the
think media community
this process that rob just took us
through now we have the insight of what
smart video to make next by just kind of
following the breadcrumbs of this tool
yeah i i think a really important word
you use the sean chalmers intuition and
i think that that starts to build up
as you um learn more about your keyword
universe and you get familiar with the
terms that are being used and you're
watching other people's content and then
you start to develop that instinct as to
yeah i know now a little bit about
youtube shorts but i know that
the question being asked all of the time
is how do i monetize my content and so
we've done a search for youtube shorts
monetization here and there's quite a
sea change in that keyword score now the
volume is high but crucially the
competition is relatively low and that
suggests to me that there's an
opportunity here for me as a creator to
maybe create content which is going to
start to rank highly on youtube and
we've proved that here where we're
ranking quite highly uh for videos about
uh youtube shorts monetization
over on the right hand side as well
we've got some interesting analytics in
terms of data
the ones that i'm looking at here in
particular are the average age
and this suggests that content for this
search term is being recycled on a
frequent basis and that means that
a lot of creators are creating content
on this topic but also there's
opportunities to rank highly
and not be in that situation where
you're maybe making a video about how to
tie a tie or how to change a tire those
evergreen topics which are well
established and it's so hard to
establish yourself because this is
well-established competition but with
something here that's quite fluid and
there's new stories coming out about
monetization all of the time maybe that
gives me an opportunity to create
content uh frequently and
is very up to date there
and also the top creator uh in this on
this occasion it's vid iq so i'll be
thinking again as a content creator if
this is the channel that's ranking
highly on a consistent basis
for this keyword i want to see what
they're up to i want to look at their
titles their thumbnails even watch their
content to find out why youtube
considers this particular creator
an authority on the subject
brilliant insights and uh super helpful
for
using a suite of tools that show up once
we start digging into our search term
but i love one of the things you said is
you got to understand your keyword
universe and so um let me ask you what
niche or what topic are you in drop that
in the comments um and i see the gaming
mom here super good to see you
she's one of our vra students but she's
doing really cool videos of course on
gaming and some breakdowns and tips or
some reviews of upcoming games
um knowing your keyword universe uh i'll
tell you ours at think media on our main
channel
it's the best tips and tools for
creators and so we talk about a lot of
cameras right and so we we know that our
keyword universe is like best camera for
youtube we also know and even today on
what we call content camp we were
talking about um the canon m50 still
being having a ton of search volume and
talking about making videos about canon
m50 accessories and some other ideas and
maybe some updated photography tips for
the canon m50 mark ii so your keyword
universe now is understanding the spider
web of ideas that could that orbit your
core topic in your niche and so um we've
got automative entertainment in the
house here um we've got uh inspiration
and motivation this is great budget
worship leaders really clear niche cool
channel name helping small churches lead
better worship on a budget thank you so
much for being here on the coffee with
kennel show
we've got the capable wife gardening
cooking and decorating
cars car reviews um and so
understanding you're having a clear
niche having a clear topic but
understanding your keyword universe um
is uh super powerful and i love that
term it helps us kind of want to drill
down and we can do that
with one of the ways is with vid iq so
what's one of the next tools and how can
we go even deeper
with vid iq
yeah this is the last tool i want to
show you on the search page for now um
we've been looking here about youtube
shots monetization
and it looks as if there's opportunity
here
but you've also got to consider your
place on youtube
and the size of your channel and when i
scroll down the list here we have this
tool that tells you the channel size
so i'm seeing channels of tens of
thousands of subscribers hundreds of
thousands of subscribers 50 thousand
subscribers
maybe me as the channel is under a
thousand subscribers perhaps even though
there is an opportunity here it may be
difficult to rank
so
on top of the keyword in terms of its
volume
you may be wanting to look at which
channels
are competing and their size and
another
question that's been asked in the
youtube shots universe is whether or not
you can create custom thumbnails
youtube in their infinite wisdom have
decided that youtube shots will not have
custom thumbnails for the time being um
but it's an interesting question and is
that going to change in the future
and so this would be
another aspect of your keyword universe
and what i'm finding here outside of the
video that we created
i'm seeing channels of a relatively
small size that are ranking for this in
a very niche topic within youtube shorts
i'm fascinated by this channel with a
hundred subscribers that had a video
with over a thousand views that to me
suggests
that there is an opportunity here for
smaller creators to break through and
that's when you go really deep into your
topic uh another example of this might
be i've seen many channels in the
fortnite universe who
solely
make content about how to improve the
gaming performance frames per second so
it might be like how to get more fps on
fortnite 2021 and this channels
i've got like you know a thousand
subscribers but they're getting tens of
thousands of views because they're
focusing on a very specific need for
that community
yeah i love that and so that tip is
once you have vidiq installed you can
see those little blue numbers next to
the channel name so it's pretty small on
screen but that just gives you at a
snapshot as you scroll on the home page
to see the channel subscriber size and
if you are seeing videos that rank
that have low subscribers or are also
getting disproportionately more views
than their subscribers one of those top
examples rob pointed to had about 129
subscribers but the video got
1 000 it's at 1200 views and the channel
only has 10 percent of that
that what you're saying is that's an
opportunity because it's showing that i
don't have to have
huge influence a ton of momentum yet if
i make the right video
based off coming up with the right
topics from the keyword research that
you're breaking down for us here oh
sweet now i can actually get in on some
action and of course the question we all
have as youtube creators
is is not necessarily how do i grow from
100 000 subscribers and beyond it's how
do i get discover when nobody knows me
yet and let me know if you can relate to
that how do i grow from zero how do i
get my first 100 subscribers my first
500 subscribers and so really lean in on
this tip because when you before you
even make a video
you're pre-determining should i attack
this topic
should this be something and and what
are the opportunities for me to grow
when i have a small channel and so that
tip is super powerful thank you for that
one uh rob what are we looking at next
yeah i remember when um clubhouse was
first released um
at the end of last year beginning of
this year and there were so many people
who wanted to know how to use clubhouse
how to get invites and there was these
small channels on youtube that were
making single videos and they were
getting tons of views but then they
didn't they didn't double down we didn't
almost turn their channels into clue
past education channels and
it was it was such an opportunity of a
time but you know six months later
clubhouse is almost yesterday's news in
in some sense but yeah we um i want to
now look at the
i guess the second side
stage of keyword research and this might
be when you've actually finished making
your video and you want to start to
optimize it
for youtube search
i made a video here about the youtube
algorithm it's something that we're
always very interested in uh here at vid
iq and so the title i've decided here is
cheat code updated that's kind of my my
hook how to further beat the youtube
algorithm in 2021 so including the the
year and uh
and all of these ideas of you know you
know the hacks the cheats all the the
shortcuts to understanding the youtube
um algorithm a little bit more and once
you start to type in any information in
your title and your description
then
in the video tag section which is much
further down the list
you will start to see that youtube is
going to vid iq is going to
automatically recommend keywords
associated with
your metadata
now there is that big question right now
about whether
video tags are important uh my advice is
always if there is a box that youtube's
providing to you
fill it
but with vidiq's tools you can do that
very very quickly so
already we've got tons of
recommendations here thanks to the tags
and so all i need to do on the
recommended tag section here is just
click
and as you can see it's now starting to
add all of these tags
very quickly if i wanted to do the warp
speed version of this then you would go
to youtube search
type in what you want to rank for and
then on one of these top ranked videos
enable inline keyword search this is one
of my favorite tools at vid iq
i just copy the tags from another video
and then go back to mine
and
we can paste all of those tags in now it
is important at this point to actually
look at these tags and try to understand
your video is probably a little
different to watch ranking on youtube so
you want to delete you want to delete
some of the tags that aren't necessarily
relevant to you that might be the
channel name for example
or maybe your video isn't necessarily
about the um algorithm for a small
youtuber it might be for
well-established youtubers so you delete
and add as appropriate and then the
final thing is once you've maybe
established a collection of keywords and
you want to use them on a regular basis
you can set up a
tag template so if i click this button
we can choose uh a collection of tags
that we've already set up for a theme or
a topic and then i've we've got the
youtube algorithm one here and we'll
just insert the tags and boom
everything's all there ready to go and i
can save it
so
yeah again going back to the question of
are tags important i think their value
is diminishing
however
when you start to understand all of
these tags and make sure they're in your
videos you have a i think marginal gain
against
channels that are not using tags
whatsoever i think that can be more
valuable as a small creator and again
it's just adding to your keyword
universe sean it's allowing you to
understand the common tongue of your
topic and it gives you fantastic video
ideas going forward as well
man i love that super super powerful and
uh if you've been getting value out of
this stream hit the like button and also
um you know this stream is brought to
you by vid iq and
um it's a tool we've been using at think
media since think media was just me in a
bedroom shooting some videos i guess i'm
still kind of in a bedroom a home office
right now um and uh and i've been using
vidiq
since it started basically and i started
with the free version so make sure you
get that installed
rob's been showing you
the vidiq vision
google chrome plug-in so you don't just
download bid iq you get that plugin
installed and now you're getting keyword
scores and all those details but if you
want to take advantage of a trial on the
boost plan which is what we use
here at think media all the time there's
a web-based app that we use we do
competitor research trend research a lot
of things we're not even going to get
into today
check a link out in the description down
below and uh make sure to get signed up
for vidiq rob one of the things that i
actually love before we get into the
next tool and then we're going to
welcome on uh ed in just a second and do
some keyword research with some people
in our community
is the fact that in my opinion yes
youtube has mentioned tags
carry uh you know less weight or almost
no way however
i think it's all about order what what
i've what i've learned
is that
by understanding your niche by
understanding your keyword universe and
by doing
research of keyword phrases which become
your tags
it shapes your content
and therefore
then your content is crafted in such a
way that it's been reverse engineered
which is like the first step in our
system our seven step system that now
when you put the video out and when the
video ranks and you know for example uh
that's someone asked when do i need to
see the little blue numbers of vid iq
telling us where our video ranks for a
particular tag well those little blue
numbers in my opinion
it's not that the tags influence ranking
as much as we think it's that their
evidence that we did our topic research
well that we did what you're showing us
well and then that the information we
gained because maybe we were going to do
a video on youtube shorts as we talked
about earlier but we weren't going to
focus on monetization
but now that has influenced our entire
content creation process
so now we're leaning in heavy in terms
of the title and description which
carries more weight youtube shorts
monetization seven things you need to
know and now we put the video out and it
ranks and it ranks for multiple tags it
ranks for multiple keyword phrases
and
we say all right that's a complete
mission we've completed the whole cycle
and so it's not as much that the magical
combination of tags did it but it is
this is the unlock in my opinion
that our
keyword research ahead of time and topic
research ahead of time and to your point
in fact stick around because we have a
bonus tip he's breaking down five tools
but where we're going to talk about the
future of keyword research into the
future of youtube
the words you're saying in your video
all those details are being influenced
by what you're showing us right now and
so anyways it's funny because there's so
much polarization where some people are
throwing out the baby with the bathwater
i think to their their loss by just
saying i'm gonna ignore tags completely
if you will
which
i'm going to ignore keyword research i
think that is yeah that's a that's a
flawed path to take and hey more
opportunity for everybody watching this
video to actually lean in it's just
having the right approach uh what do you
think
i couldn't agree more with i i think if
you are doing the research beforehand
you're planning etc etc
the act of actually filling in that box
of tags should take no more than 60
seconds because it's already it's
already instinctively all there
you know what your video is about
because it's been shaped by the keyword
research it's just the case of typing in
the tags or pasting them in however you
want to look at it and yeah i think
you're right in a sense that now i think
the tag box almost
it almost indicates how well it was
optimized as opposed to that that
contributed to the optimization uh to
begin with
awesome well i'm excited we got more
tools uh and so uh let's let's jump into
the next one
yeah um
the one thing uh that i did want to just
mention as well um sean as you were
talking about the
chrome extension is we do actually have
a mobile version of the keyword research
as well so you don't just have to do it
on a desktop and we have an app if you
wanted to download that as well
now um
the
question of what's going to happen
with youtube seo
keyword research in the future
i'm start now starting to frame
a concept of content engine optimization
which isn't just about what you write in
the description
what you're writing tags and titles
or thumbnails it's actually the content
of a video themselves and i've started
to discover this
new uh data that youtube is unearthing
to viewers as they search i think it's
in its very early stages in terms of
showing viewers um cert
youtube searchers
what they're interested in but um
i've done a very specific search here um
to show you that
youtube is now definitely
listening or at least reading the
captions of your content for example uh
we've done a search here for you've just
started your youtube channel all right
it's not a search that you would do
every single day but consider where this
might be in two or three years time
youtube is picking up what i'm actually
saying in the video
we've
thought this to be true for a number of
years but we've always wondered if it
was maybe the first 30 seconds the first
minute but as you can see on screen
there are three results here where
youtube is specifically picking up what
i'm saying in the captions at 20 34
seconds
two minutes in
10 minutes into a video youtubers dug
that deep into a video to try and work
out what i'm searching for and give as a
result
so it's very clear that what you say in
your videos can start to influence how
your content is found
this though is what blew my mind when i
was just doing some random searches a
couple of weeks ago
this one here sean it's a video about
youtube seo uh but i think i do say
something along the lines of if you're
starting a youtube channel
so i'm not not saying i actually wrote
this in
the um on this on the video
so can you see what it says on screen
now
text detected in video
what on earth does that actually mean
well if i click on that link it should
take me to the exact place in the video
what it's telling me
is that this
text here
you just started your youtube channel is
matching up to the search i put into
youtube
and i find that incredible that youtube
is starting to do that
i've tried to do some tests on this
where i hold up a piece of paper which
has a phrase
and then search on youtube but it hasn't
given me any results just yet so i think
this is just the very beginning of
youtube testing out
not only looking at your titles
thumbnails tags whatnot but also looking
at images in your videos and you know
the text on screen and
i think we've heard before that you know
when mr beast is uh
has a video and he's going maybe to a
he's buying some food from walmart
youtube is able to identify that you
know the different foods are appearing
and because people are searching
for maybe
an apple or a peach because mr beast
gets so many views his videos are
strangely appearing in those search
results but as i say
i'm just doing some initials testing
right now i don't know
how when this is going to start to
develop more but i think as we go
forward i think keyword research is
always going to be important
but including that keyword research
actually in what you're recording on
screen i think is going to get even more
important
that was some serious bomb drops right
there and the term that you're kind of
coining is not search engine
optimization it's content
engine optimization yeah it doesn't
abbreviate it very well because it's
youtube ceo
you're like is it susan you're like yeah
uh but um yeah and i love that because
i mean we're seeing some of the same
things and it's that google is scanning
for the here's the takeaways the b-roll
in the video the visuals do the visuals
reinforce the promise of the title do
your words
say phrases that people might be
interested in and some of the things
we've been tapping into probably beyond
what we can even cover today but time
steps chapters and how you title your
chapters that can start ranking in
google because google wants to serve up
the best answer for a specific specific
inquiry for the end user and so by
optimizing your content in terms of
scripting how you're setting things up
what you're saying in your video what
you're showing in your video
um
be on the back end of understanding your
keyword universe understanding your
niche understanding the end user um is
incredibly powerful i know we've thrown
a lot of
technical and speak at you and i'm
excited to even cover some of this stuff
uh just continually in depth because
obviously this is a big topic and that's
the mission here at think media is to
help you crush it on youtube and really
figure some of these things out so if
you've been getting value hit like we're
going to welcome ed on in just a second
um and a couple other guests and we're
actually going to now dive into some
keyword research and their specific
niches for their specific channels but
huge shout out to rob from vidiq joining
us today if you haven't gotten your 30
day free trial of vid iq
what are you thinking uh
vidiq.com link in the description down
below as well where you can check that
out and um
highly highly uh more than highly
recommend it it's a tool that we use
consistently here
at think media in the future we're going
to be doing more episodes on coffee with
cannell because
we use vidiq for trending we use vid iq
for some new tools that are actually
coming out soon that we've got our hands
on the beta versions that have been just
an absolute game changer um as well as
we also like spying on our competitors
and there's a cool way that we do that
with vid iq as well
but rob are you um ready to go and we're
gonna dive into some channels um of some
of our
vra students awesome so ed welcome
to
the
show coffee with kennel uh go ahead and
unmute your mic and then rob if you
wanna pull up the channel and this is
helpful if you can put your channel name
at your channel name for anybody else
that's coming on uh in the queue that
way it could be easy we'll get a second
here to pull up the channel so we can
maybe get a look at it a vibe on the
channel but ed uh tell us a little bit
about yourself and what your channel's
all about and maybe some of the upcoming
video ideas you have so we can do some
keyword research with you
awesome awesome yo it was uh so good to
be with you guys vra fam um i am ed
oyama i produce electronic kind of dance
hip-hoppy stuff at oyama's music uh
very new channel just a month old
uh what did i say helping beginning
beatmakers breakthrough on a budget nice
so that's what i'm about and um
yeah i just recently started live
streaming so that's kind of like the
first few up here
and you can kind of tell when i started
doing uh vra because the thumbnails got
a lot more specific
so yeah before that i was just posting
music to see if it could get some
traction
i love it and i you know initially i
think about helping beginning beat
makers is a really clear
um
niche you know one of our vra students
matthew uh creates um he
he does npc videos and he
he's been a nurse last couple years
recently went full time if you know
matthew um but uh yeah rob dive in let's
let's do a little brainstorming and ed
if you
uh
maybe rob what are some of your initial
thoughts
yes i'm just trying
music is a really tricky uh topic um
because i i think and sean you were
talking about this um during one of our
channel audits and there's there's
either musicians who want to entertain
other musicians who want to educate and
i think we really need to establish that
as quickly as possible so so ed i'm
guessing you're falling into the
uh former camp of being a an educator in
how to make beat music would that be
correct
that is correct absolutely yeah and is
there a particular type of beat music
because now i need to learn your keyword
universe you know your common tongue
right right right so i i got the pro vit
iq i have it kind of running in the back
over here but some of the things that
i'm going after would be like ableton
ableton beginner tutorials so there's an
app called ableton i can type that into
chat oh yeah
i can see on your um
yeah that's the powerful one i know
ableton is i think one of the main
versions of the software is 500
um and you know i i kind of always think
about what's the business model but if
you think about ranking for a new
version of of ableton and i think
sometimes software could be ten percent
um or more but i think even on amazon i
was looking up because we had uh my
friend miguel had a channel where he was
helping people because years ago so
there's multiple new ableton
um
uh ableton push 2 i'm not actually
looking at amazon okay so that's a
that's a physical product
right and that's
um interesting but okay uh yeah let's uh
what do you got uh rob are you looking
some stuff up
yes i'm just um
i just picked one of the um search
results
and i'm seeing straight away here this
is an exciting one for me uh channel
with less than 300 subscribers a video
with 30 000 views
now i'm not necessarily saying that you
um do a kendrick lamar beats uh video
but
it'd be interesting to know why this
video
uh found so much traction
and
is it through for the keywords is it it
was kendrick lamar particularly popular
artist at the time or is it something
revolutionary that they showed as a
tutorial within that video and if
anything's changed because it's four
years old and it's still ranking very
highly can i perhaps create an updated
video on that particular topic i haven't
even looked at the inline keywords yet
so
this is a good example of a type of
keyword universe that's being used by
these creators
so as i start to understand a little bit
more about this ableton keyword that's
what i'm initially discovering
um yeah and i was i'm looking here at uh
how do i just share my entire am i
sharing the right window here
why that's the not right window
there we go
all right
so if i look at this
i think i think deep dive tutorials this
this makes me think i mean right now
we're using just auto predict
we found on think media that like high
value rich content
and and the trouble is
tutorial could be so exhaustive but
maybe it's like the first few steps to
get started
but the nice thing about software is
there's always a new
version coming out um and so
uh
11 10 ableton versus fl studio that
could be a good one for our versus
strategy
but if we come over to our vid iq
keyword inspector here this is how i
might jump into
the keyword universe of ableton in
general and how we use it a lot
is i might go search volume and just
look for where where like what's the
size of the topic ableton live 11
interesting and and very low you know so
even we could dig a little deeper into
researching that
um
and
certainly tutorial here
sometimes i think about combinations we
can make like
how to make edm
able
dash you're stacking two things ableton
live 11
and uh they're both
in this sort of the same universe and if
that was the style of music you could
maybe show i'm going to show you a
couple beginner tips for uh in a
tutorial of how to use ableton live 11
and get started with that and then
what's interesting is understanding your
keyword universe again i actually you
know amazon works similarly to youtube
with the auto predict so if you're if
you're trying to understand the mindset
of
uh in this particular case the mindset
of the end user ableton push controllers
are interesting do you happen to have
one of those ed or no
i don't have that one but i have another
one i actually have it in the back right
here it's called a launch key it's like
okay on the fridge let me grab it
a launch key
so this is the launch key mini mark iii
and i picked that up recently it's a
great piece of gear
yep
yep and so uh that also becomes you know
launch key mini mark iii over here
um
yes and same idea uh ableton setup and
so i mean
yeah sometimes i also think
it's a this using some of rob's tips you
know well the top ranked video is 2 000
subs not super big
um and 5 minutes long success leaves
clues so it's maybe a quick introduction
smart use of chapters on this video here
um
top down shot of the launch key and then
basically
just getting straight into it
so is any of that
have you got any ideas so far has this
been uh
helpful
oh absolutely because i've got like a
lot of niche little ideas a little bit
of light trend surfing like some new
software came out that attaches to
ableton basically i'm doing like a
versus thing tonight on that but
wow like
that that success leaves clues what a
gem searching the amazon launch key
autofills
yeah
i was just looking in the background and
i think i found the perfect channel for
you to
follow um okay this area because um i we
saw that ableton live 11 was quite a um
a opportunity rich keyword and so i
found this channel
this particular video four thousand
views 300 subscribers three months old
but when you click into his channel
click the wrong one there we just go
there and then look at the videos every
single video he makes he's punching
above his weights you know he's getting
thousands of views on each of his videos
and so i think there's a good example
there of the style of thumbnail he's
branded himself really well
and you know anything where he's talking
about ableton
i'm not saying that you should
necessarily copy the videos but this is
an example of a creator who's really
finding their their little corner of
youtube and starting to grow out with
with this piece of software
yeah rob that's a brilliant insight and
i think also when you start seeing a
niche like that you know sometimes you
you observe a niche fortnight
uh
that iq channel covers gaming a lot and
fortnite's crazy minecraft's crazy
competitive you take something like that
and there's
nice it's nice to identify a potential
niche and kind of a sub niche it doesn't
mean your channel needs to become
ableton but it might mean that there's
50 to 100 to 250 videos you could go
deep on and there might only be one two
three creators in the space
and and and you especially could think
in some sub niches like that that if
you're in like the top 10
creating consistent quality content
there's a ton of abundance to be had
there in regards to uh serving different
topics related to that and there's such
a long tale of pl best plugins
this plug-in versus that plug-in for
ableton
and drilling down in some of those
things um and uh
and so that was a that was a really good
insight so
and for everybody watching
who are some of the creators in your
space you could learn from not copy but
that you could study which videos are
doing well and the key term that rob
used was punching above their weight
class
what that reveals to us is that small
channels
can jump into that proven and even
profitable niche
and and get a lot of traction because
it's not as much david going against the
goliath of
established fortnight creators but
jumping into something um specific like
ableton the launch key
and and the 100 to 200 to 300 plus
videos that are related probably just to
launch key and ableton um as well as i
don't know the difference between
ableton live versus the other versions
ancillary third-party plug-ins i mean i
think it's important to have that kind
of vision and realize that if you stay
creating consistent content
you've got almost unlimited videos you
could make and uh you pump those out on
a regular basis and the last thought i
was thinking there as well was this this
idea of
when you do what that channel that rob
discovered is doing
and you've got that consistent looking
thumbnail and that consistent topic
that's the best way to create a snowball
effect on your channel because people
will fall into the rabbit hole of
ableton
and and do a bingeable session because
you're you're you're clear on what
you're teaching so basically
someone watches the one thing well that
was really good i resonated with that
person oh i also want to know how do i
set up the synth thing and that gets
recommended next so by building out in
your early stages of your channel by
building out
50 75 150 ableton videos there's going
to be the 10 to 20 percent that probably
just crush
um and and they start suggesting each
other and you'll be reaping the rewards
that's the video raked academy
philosophy it's the understanding the
power of youtube that we make videos
today strategically that are going to
get views for weeks months and years to
come
circular video viralocity they suggest
themselves to themselves and once the
viewer identifies that they just they
just got a launch key for christmas they
just got a launch key on black friday
they come home they sit down and they go
to youtube and boom they fall into the
rabbit hole of his content as well
because it'll cross promote as well as
your own videos and people just navigate
their way through and you're chilling
with your family on vacation but you're
getting views while you snooze
i get a little fired up hey ed has that
been helpful
oh my gosh that was so crazy helpful i
love it i love it and tony's in the back
here firing great ideas at me i'm just
like watching these it's amazing so i
also
like what you've tested previously ed
hearing that you've tried to do i guess
this would be called celebrity jacking
where you're
trying to um you know make beats based
on on kanye i'm wondering if you could
maybe now transfer that to ableton like
how to
make beats like blank
using a ableton um
that might be something to explore as
well
no that's a great idea yeah that
actually got a lot of con traction so i
found an
ai chat bot that could emulate kanye
west's voice and it was really funny to
me but i thought oh what a fun intro
video for my channel i can guest kanye
robot
so to do that with ableton that would be
really awesome somehow i got to think
about that a bit
that's awesome ed well hey i want to get
to a couple other people really
appreciate you and thanks so much for
coming on today
hey my pleasure this has been awesome
very cool thank you so much have a good
day ed
coffee with kennel crew uh take a sip of
water get ready we're gonna bring
somebody else on we're diving into their
channels keyword research wise but smash
like if you begin value and let me know
uh what your aha moment was was from
this training so far or specifically
what video following along with these
tips do you need to make next not what
what next five videos your mind might be
buzzing what's the one video you should
make next that's the most strategic
that's maybe the easiest for you to
create because it would just flow from
your knowledge currently
let us know in the comments and coming
up next we've got
uh james joining us james i think we've
dropped your channel in the private chat
but i want to make sure rob has a second
to get to your channel
um james how's it going uh where are you
joining us from and tell us a little bit
about your channel
yeah i'm uh first of all can you hear me
great
yeah
awesome awesome uh yeah i'm coming from
des moines iowa and my channel is 21st
century educator i am a 15-year educator
a vet and
i had
done a little testing through a video
game channel but this was the one that i
wanted to take seriously and so you know
i put out that first video punch fear in
the face and
you know um
got it out there and it's been up for 48
hours got about 50 views on it and i've
already got there's so much in education
right now that uh
you can jump into and so
i'm hoping to
get a little strategy here
i love it and as rob pulls up uh he's
got your channel pulled up tell us your
keyword universe a little bit who are we
talking to and what kind of
um
you know videos and search terms are a
starting point yeah so uh the first
thing is just taking us through the the
mindset of the teacher going through
their school year
and so starting off at this time most
teachers are probably working on you
know thinking about their classroom
management and so classroom management
basics was i thought a logical place to
start and i'm thinking about things that
way i've already got the the next video
in mind of you know knowing that covid
and you know we're now having kids
coming back in full force and so you
know thinking about what kind of uh
teaching style is going to lend itself
best to
um managing students who were some will
be wearing math some won't be wearing
masks
you know all the behavior concerns and
and making sure that you're teaching in
such a way that uh gets the job done but
at the same time welcomes
uh kids to you know feel safe and
comfortable in the environment
brilliant rob
uh hi hi james um
so i think the first question i would
ask and it's kind of been driven by
um
the youtube
search predictions here is do you have a
certain target audience in terms of uh
the um age of the students are we
talking school preschool
uh college well currently i'm uh middle
school myself and so we're looking at
that middle school to high school age
but my thought is that any beginning or
even veteran teacher could get some use
out of things because
you know you can always brush up on some
things but uh i would say the major
target audience would be beginning
teachers
yeah yeah and i think also given the
time of year i'm not sure when the uh
when when is it back to school usually
in the u.s it's for canada it's labor
day the day after yeah towards the last
uh
like we're starting back on august 25th
and so
now i wanted to kind of put this out a
little bit ahead of that and as people
are starting to think about teachers you
know um
like to savor as much of that summer as
possible so we didn't want to put
something out too soon
first day classroom management maybe
first day of school classroom management
and that feels like a very long tail
keyword there i'm wondering what we
could possibly find here
one i saw james
there was a first day classroom
activities that popped up
would that be the right type of video
talking to your target audience would is
it teachers that would want to get
information like that or no
uh yeah i believe so i would say there's
a lot of different ways to go about
either classroom management or
activities first five days first three
days
teaching styles and
lots of different ways to go there
so
first first day classroom activities is
interesting
and
classroom activities
i wonder if you go yeah middle school
and um
and so this is interesting rob what's
your take on
going broad but not attracting maybe
your
very specific ideal audience but maybe
getting more views or really trying to
niche down because for instance even
here
elementary middle school high school
it's a pretty broad and here she's not
even
specifying what are your thoughts on uh
on tackling something like just
classroom activities in general yeah i
think um because james you are very
early on in your youtube journey i think
you have a luxury of experimenting
because although you may think your
target audience is middle middle school
as as you push out maybe 20 25 videos
you realize that it might be going in a
slightly different direction and
teachers of
certain
pupil age might be gravitating more
towards your content um i think
ultimately the data that you get from
your content is going to maybe help
direct you in the right direction uh and
i also think because as you said for a
lot of um students pupils this may be
the first time they're going back to
school
uh after the pandemic lock down
that's going to have some recency in
terms of keyword
keywords that you would use you've just
got to be careful of how youtube is
treating
such content in terms of making sure
that the information is correct and
you're guiding your viewers along the
right path which i'm sure you will be
but you know kobe 19 and youtube starts
to
not raise concerns but you just have to
be careful with the type of content that
you're creating
yeah i appreciate that i've been paying
very close attention uh one of the
things i wanted to consider was you know
the fact that yeah covet is a thing and
you know how you might want to navigate
through those things and definitely
doing the research on that
yeah and james
here's kind of my line of thinking of uh
you know generating some ideas
so
we kind of had this classroom activities
middle school
um i jump over here to vid iq hit the
keyword inspector up
and this then uh i like to see the
search volume on youtube here
and then we dug down to what you already
are doing which would be like classroom
management strategies and it's good to
see that there's you know 8259 uh
people searching a month
low uh search you know competition so
good to go deep on that it reminds me of
one strategy that our friend jeremy vest
talks about calling it nested keywords
and so i sometimes think about when you
find one keyword like classroom
management strategies um that becomes
you eventually would want to have 50 100
videos with that in the title and maybe
the nested keyword means that's at the
end and there's something like
how to your first day of
school with kobit restrictions
parentheses or at the end classroom
management strategies and it's about
like really going deep and dominating
the the niche for me it might be like
seven tips for shooting better better
50s uh better photos canon m50 camera
and it's like the first promise with the
one thing you really want to go super
deep on and that's kind of called like
nested keywords but then
we'll definitely be covering this in a
future episode what i love is that vidiq
gives us these trending videos right by
the side
of our keyword research and i spend
almost
most of my time here so i just start
with kind of a basic this is why you
want to understand your universe for
everybody watching then it's like okay
classroom setup a lot of classroom setup
final classroom setup
success leaves clues it's like we
started with classroom activities
and like all of the views per hour
velocity type videos are about classroom
setup now you don't necessarily want
that to steer you towards content you
wouldn't normally create
classroom tour
um but that certainly gives some
insights there and then this is one of
my favorite things
i'd i like to come over with
understanding your keyword just to
google
do classroom management strategies and
i'm curious about what are the top
ranked blog posts eight proactive
classroom management tips for new
teachers and i'm like
great there's my next video i got five
proactive classroom tips like even a
little bit of a title insight
realizing that google owns youtube and
so you might be able to
create a valuable video that answers
something that's already kind of ranking
in text format or blog format youtube
loves that that um
video content and i know it's i know
this stuff takes work but crafting that
content clarifying your big idea
we're all about keyword research here we
kind of went through our thinking of
having the intuition mixed with
following the keyword down like a rabbit
hole and following breadcrumbs crafting
our idea then
creating uh a a training like that
that's reinforced by the words you're
saying in the video the closed
captioning even chapters along the eight
tips and there's the ability to rank on
the first page of google which is
probably
i would think it actually is probably a
bigger
teachers are probably starting there and
we have a
we got 2 million views on think media
in 2020 from google search traffic
external and we really don't have a
website it was from just
clips of videos and moments of videos
and whole videos ranking on google
itself but that happens because of the
process you know we're really describing
here by reverse engineering the big idea
crafting the content well thinking about
what is the language the end user uses
which another way to say that is what is
the keywords what are the words the end
user uses has this been helpful james at
all getting any uh insights and some
fresh inspiration for your channel
yeah actually it has and i'm in a unique
position because i'm actually a part of
the administrative team so it gives me a
little more leeway to maybe
get into some classrooms and get some
thoughts from some teachers as well so
yeah appreciate it very much
awesome james we appreciate you and uh
thank you so much for jumping on
all right have a good day james
appreciate you
rob i think we're going to try to get to
uh one or two more for sure we have
randall up next um but uh hit like if
you've been getting value there's been a
fun
training let me know if you um want to
have
rob back on coffee with kannel
it's predestined because we just got i
got too many questions for him uh in
terms of uh some of the other tools i
want to dig into and man there's just so
many different approaches to youtube i
want to encourage you meaning
approaches to how you craft your videos
there's following the trends there's
learning from your competitors there's
the keyword research topic research and
so uh if you haven't subscribed here on
our think media podcast channel yet
definitely do that this is our coffee
with kennel show today i'm drinking a
live seltzer cucumber focus drink so i
violated the promise of the entire show
but let me know what you're drinking
drop it in the comments down below and
today we're talking all about keyword
research if you happen just to be
joining um please
shout me out where you're watching from
and today's episode is brought to you by
vid iq
a a partner sponsor but also someone who
we've loved far before we've ever worked
with professionally
because they're the absolute best in
class youtube software
for
topic research keyword research
following trends we're going to talk
about the channel audit tool in the
future we're going to talk about new
tools of some innovative uh team of
developers have been working on to give
you an edge when it comes to youtube so
hit up vidiq.com forward slash think uh
to get a 30 day free trial of their
boost plan which is where you get some
of these more advanced tools that we're
looking at as we open up some
of the people's channels that are
joining us well hey we got randall
randall where are you watching from and
uh arting with randall
tell us a little bit about your channel
yeah i'm
i'm in alberta canada i'm in a tiny
little hamlet named rosebud and my
channel is called arting with randall
and the focus
it's a new channel so it's kind of broad
at this point still trying to figure
things out but basically i'm trying to
um
to encourage inspire give demos and
instruction to anybody
that is uh has aspirations to make
visual art and maybe has some blockages
considering that
surrounding
art education
artists are an inspiration
i guess you're spoiled for choice when
it comes to youtube backgrounds because
that looks pretty awesome
well thanks
yeah and uh i'm outnumbered now rob
where are you streaming from
vancouver bc
i'm also in
canada as well
and i'm coming to you from seattle
washington but i'm fired up the
channel's looking great and yeah that
the art behind you is looking absolutely
beautiful so uh
what are um
some of the
videos you're thinking about making next
or do you have an idea of what your
keyword
universe is well i i just did a a search
i think was on uh ask the public
and one of the questions that came up a
lot was can i learn to draw by tracing
and i should i need to do a video on
that and the answer would be not really
but i've got a way that'll work
and that's similar it's almost tracing
and you will actually develop skill so
that's the one i would i would want to
do
but i just
i i put up one just now uh two days ago
three days ago and i just didn't think
i'd ever do this that's that fast
painting secrets
and i just
it's a static well it's a static shot
recording of me painting for 55 minutes
live at a concert and then i went back
and i went i won't post this but i threw
in a commentary
and i just talked for 55 minutes and
i got to admit i've got a bit of a group
in in facebook that i sent over here but
i didn't expect that i'd get this many
views this quickly or any at all
and my view times are also up
no that's awesome and i think this also
speaks to some stuff i mean clearly
you're incredible what you do
i can see you know you're involved in
your community here and whatnot and that
speaks to some of those
uh the important aspect of youtube of
community building and as you build one
subscriber at a time and as they make a
bond with you and and those
relationships that form so i love that i
also want to mention it just stuck out
to me since lewis house is a friend
and this definitely is that kind of
trend surfing influence surfing idea but
it's cool to see
that uh you did a sketch of a known
person
um and uh where did he get 800 likes um
well and that was in a private facebook
group
i was attending a workshop where he
spoke and he thought somebody had done a
sketch of them and put it up and they
hadn't they just threw up
something they already had and so while
he was talking for the 20 minutes i
sketched him and then i played oh that's
done it's not going to do anything i
posted it in the private facebook group
for that event
you know and it blew up in that group
but i mean
and i know we're talking about keyword
research but that's the kind of thing i
mean i would i would continue to do that
because i would also do that with your
facebook profile hopefully optimized to
a degree maybe you change your cover
image that mentions you have a youtube
channel make sure that your youtube
channel is easy to find
the key there right friends is that it's
not about going into like facebook
groups and spamming your channel it's
about going into facebook groups in this
case
adding something to the conversation you
you're part of an entrepreneurial event
a learning event you've got this drawing
skill you drop that people are like oh
that's so cool it gets 800 likes
some click on your profile and like oh
man i'm kind of you know vibing with
this guy like this this stuff is cool
let me ch oh he's got randall's got a
youtube channel and and that's how a few
bonds can happen one at a time and so uh
that's kind of a cool thing to discover
right um right there but uh rob uh any
thoughts as you're uh pulling up the
channel
yeah so randall i've just been looking
at the channel in the background and
what i'm finding curious is that
today i don't feel as if you've really
been targeting
keyword phrases
it's more being um actually building a
community you know some of your titles
are what's next you decide and usually
when we we're talking to channels we
would say well hang on who is searching
for that how is the content going to be
discovered but there's some very
encouraging numbers here you have over
100 subscribers already congratulations
on our first milestone
but but each of these some of these
community videos that i would classify
are getting a decent number of views
which is encouraging um but i don't feel
as if you've really
utilized um
any search driven content to it to a
great degree yet i think the one thing i
question is as a as a complete um
new bto channel is is the content uh or
done through technology you know like an
ipad or tablet or is it through um you
know hand hand art because i think that
might be something to
to establish if possible
yeah i'm doing a bit of both so should i
specialize in one or the other
well i think it's too early to do that
yet i think maybe in the future you'll
start to
discover whether or not your audience is
gravitating more towards one or the
other um you're in the experimental
phase so you can do um
you know
i would say after 25 50 videos you
should have enough data on whether or
not people are watching a certain type
of content right another one i think i'm
going to do
very quickly is
digital or real you know which way
should you go and do a comparison and
here's the pros and cons of each now
that as a title idea is a fantastic one
the versus video i o i mean there's
three types of
search intent videos i recommend it's
the simple how to
the listicle and the verses because when
you do versus videos you're combining
two keywords
uh and you're also um creating
i guess an opinion one way or the other
and even if somebody
maybe there's a disagreement in the
video
it generates a good conversation within
a community that you're starting to grow
all right that just confirms it that's
got to be probably the next one or one
of the next ones i create
awesome uh randall has this been helpful
oh very much yeah just listening in on
the whole thing and uh yeah getting some
very specific
responses uh because i
i feel like my my
channel is a little weird compared to
what everyone else is talking about and
it is community driven and uh so it's
nice to have some very specific stuff to
the channel
um i want to encourage you and everybody
else i mean hey i think that the
community driven side is a very powerful
thing that you'll want to lean into
uh but be
sometimes
don't overthink it sometimes
uh think about just the practical and
simple things that you can do um you
know
i saw you've done some acrylic painting
so i simply looked at
a acrylic painting using the keyword uh
inspector tool a different approaches
you can take is the idea of
going by uh
very low competition
and then scrolling up to maybe the
highest keywords
uh search volume with the lowest
competition so
you start looking at maybe
um let's see how to paint a thunderstorm
i mean
it's interesting like that if you could
paint a thunderstorm like you know
um yeah so that's that's kind of cool
how to paint pond water
um
answer specific questions and use these
powerful tools to look for how to paint
feathers this is interesting because
some of those on some specific and so
that what i did was i i put the
competition to the lowest started
started with acrylic painting as a jump
off point
um and again what we're looking for
friends right is that the synergy of
of course maybe an idea comes to us from
our research that we had never
that we don't even want to create so we
go figure out how to create it but the
goal is it's at the intersection of wait
a minute he just randomly said it oh i
could do a thunderstorm like i never
would have thought of it so it's like at
the intersection of you've got your
passion your proficiency and your skills
and then you go into that is there kind
of a market for it what's the search
volume for it um and and it's at the
intersection of those things like i
could do a thunderstorm the data backs
it up this is going to be a good use of
my time and some of those practical
search based ones also they might not be
have the as as much crazy potential but
those are the type of videos for for big
views at the start those are the type of
videos that um
go crazy
three years later
five years later
eight years later and if you catch that
kind of vision for your youtube channel
i know that's a per it takes persistence
commitment consistency
but if you think man i really want to be
making a full-time living in the uh you
know as a creator
as a content entrepreneur
um years later you've built these assets
that are bringing in adsense that are
bringing in awareness that are bringing
in subscribers and that happens from
just making one smart video
at a time
um
randall
then get value
my man
cheers coffee with kennel i think we've
all lost your audio uh but uh thank you
so much for coming on
oh there i was sorry i was i was muted
absolutely fantastic i'm drinking club
soda with a shot of green tea hey come
on
cheers no one's drinking coffee today on
coffee with kennel but uh thank you so
much for coming on randall really
appreciate you
and uh
shout out to canada rob and randall
crushing it holding it down um
uh okay we uh are gonna do a couple more
rob uh
you good like people you asked somebody
that in the front of everybody no i'm
not i gotta jump uh but uh you have uh
time for uh one more i'm good for samoa
yep
okay cool maybe do uh we'll we'll do a
couple rapid fire ones we've got uh
adrian
the capable wife
uh how's it going
hey guys it's going well i'm here in
mississippi summit mississippi how y'all
doing
summit mississippi uh
we're doing good how uh and fired up
tell us a little bit about your channel
well my channel is called capable white
and i do perennial gardening tropical
gardening
as well as kitchen gardening and i want
to get into home decorating too just
everything that a capable wife is always
doing
awesome well rob i'm curious your hot
take on that value proposition
um as uh that was that was kind of
stated before we get into maybe some
keyword research
i i love the channel name i i think
that's um a very memorable one so that's
a very good start it ranks very well on
google
yeah yeah very much so
um
i i guess one word of caution is that it
sounds like you're trying to cover a lot
of things on a lot of different topics
to begin with but you know as we say for
when creators are first starting out uh
you're you you have a license to have
fun and enjoy the journey
i think at some point
it may become apparent that your
audience is gravitating maybe towards a
particular type of gardening or when
you're in the kitchen because i think
those are two quite separate topics
certainly in terms of a keyword universe
but i don't think you need to make that
decision uh just yet uh i see you
experimenting with youtube shorts as
well uh that that's a
certainly a new area and uh yeah you're
getting some nice views there from some
of the youtube shots which is brilliant
to see
yeah and one of my first observations
was you know you started off strong with
the gardening content i liked that value
proposition that you mentioned but then
i saw like one of the most recent videos
is it accurate that it's actually
maybe your husband talking about an
edger
yes you see i'm i got to get them
involved see we're a team
yeah i want him involved even if i have
to transfer him over to a different
channel okay you know but you know uh
what i like is that he is getting into
it as well
and so any tips you can give me is well
well worth it thank you
i'm curious sean what's your attitude
and to including uh diy in the title
because we've had this conversation
sometimes on our channel audits that in
the world in the in the universe of
youtube diy can mean anything to anyone
and maybe it's more sensible to be just
straight down the middle down the line
with your title instead of diy how to
prune uh
khanna lily he should be
how to prune a canna lily in less than
five minutes i'm wondering if that may
be a more exciting uh style of approach
for some of the titles here because i
think very early what earlier on um the
titles were very very simple they were
almost like file names some of these but
now they're starting you're starting to
add a bit more
um intrigue uh to win the click
i'm looking at these ones here where i
think it's just you're describing the
the plants but nothing else um we can
make them maybe a little more exciting
both in terms of keyword research and
making it more intriguing and exciting
to win the click from the viewer
yeah i think that's that's the that is
definitely i would agree 100
the uh the big idea that i think you
could take away here is
a couple things
practically
i think the titles could be should be
longer i went to most popular videos and
not longer for long sake longer because
they should be based around long tail
keyword ideas
secondly
they should be viewer based in terms of
adding value to the viewer or serving a
prom for the viewer
so even though it actually happens to be
you know
getting views via shorts and maybe
because it's entertaining because they
are it's exactly what it is frogs in the
garden
frogs in the garden to me
is just a statement
right and if i think about let me ask
you this our years is your goal to
actually help
potential other wives learn how to
develop a set of skills
to that that wives would want to learn
is that accurate or is that in it well
you are you you're dead on with that my
goal is to help beginner
uh gardeners and beginner hunt well new
homeowners as well as new wives you know
yes
so in that case then
i would want to
avoid
if you will even titles that are like my
little pick me up
first of all that starts with you in a
way not the viewer and i understand your
heart is to show the viewer bring
inspiration the viewer
but
there's just such a even harvest from a
small garden it's like okay well if i
want to see your harvest
so
the kind of the two big ideas are rather
than front garden refresh
it's almost like maybe starting to play
with how to
refresh your garden
now that's the viewer in mind
three tips for refreshing your garden
and so
if we go garden refresh and then
i think we have to
the point of the topic research is
you're posting all these videos and i
want to commend you for your consistency
and the momentum you've already built
but i think the point is that it's at
the research stage but that's why we say
research before you press record where
we actually want to reverse engineer the
videos we should be making
and so
let me see how to
i'm going to go improve
my garden soil
so it's see this isn't even my niche
right and rob if you if you put him over
your garden like it's going to go bad
quick like he doesn't have this skill
set so um but you might not have thought
about um
you know how to improve garden soil
before planting this is the power of
keyword research could you make that
video could you teach me about garden
soil at all
i can do that yeah all i need is a soil
kit you know it's simple
there you go so see that's so that's
we've discovered it's something you know
but what we're doing is we're learning
it's also an intersection of what you
know and could teach about
with
what um
the audience might care about so now by
we're inside of the vidiq keyword
inspector well how do i improve garden
soil and this right here this search
volume
sure there's uh the idea of like oh i
only want to do big ideas or
the search volumes too low to me i don't
worry about it too much here's what i'm
doing in keyword research i'm just
trying to verify
and make and see if my video idea is
legitimate and solid because our goal
right is to make a lot of videos and
sometimes we can overestimate what it
will be or what it will turn into but in
tips on improving garden soil to me if
i'm you and you just told me you could
share those pretty easily it's just a
no-brainer video i'd lean into that and
i'd start building around this
um clay soil is interesting so how to
amend clay soil
isn't is is something that and we're
we're just diving right in and pulling
videos that would be worth making right
like that are going to be in my opinion
worth your time to create um and
i i play around with the order up here
most used or search volume now i'm going
to the highest search volumes and
looking around at things like
how to fix clay soil a lot of stuff
about soil and then things
although this does say vegetable
gardening to me that's that's still too
broad so so you want to avoid that's why
i say longer titles vegetable gardening
for beginners maybe you said you want to
help new homeowners vegetable gardening
for beginners at home
now
even if we threw out some of the stuff
that rob said earlier
like even if you don't study the
competition even if you don't
think about what anybody else is doing
even if all you do is just the keyword
research we just did i would rather see
a video titled vegetable gardening for
beginners at home than front garden
refresh now i understand it's a short so
that's that's just a little quickie but
even like
less hardscape more softscape like
that's a statement to me
how do i and i don't and i'd want to see
videos that are really built out
vegetable gardening at home for
beginners
five tips like there's a title idea
that's a real content uh a rich
video that i know there's gonna be some
value there that's organized and
structured and um that i think
will sort of
be helpful
shorts is maybe a little bit different
at times but the more concrete our video
idea is based on our research
understanding our end viewer and knowing
exactly what kind of value we want to
add to them i think the better results
you'll get uh as it comes to growing
your channel does that make sense
absolutely thanks so much sean thanks
rob i appreciate it
i i was also a nursing as well that you
are a content machine i mean making
content is not a problem so i had to
piggyback onto what sean was saying
think about when you're creating one
piece of content how can you leave the
audience wanting more from you so it's
it's not necessarily that you're
creating a part two or a part three or a
part four but there's a natural
evolution from taking a viewer from a
complete beginner
to
giving them enough information to get
them started on on their projects as
you're teaching them
and then almost thinking about where
you're going to guide them next
for the next video i know sean you do
this so expertly in your content where
you
you may be talking about keyword
research but the next natural thing is
after keyword research you want to be
researching your competition and you do
that by watching this video over here i
think it's as you were saying creating
that almost like an ecosystem within
youtube where
the content has been recommended to the
viewer is your own content so you've got
that feedback loop building up more and
more views and watch time
yeah absolutely you know i was looking
at one uh how to
well planting incredibles proven winter
incredibles
and it came up and it ranked high
and it was low competition
but
vidiq rob of course you know this it
said
that a smaller channel
should
go for the medium
go with the medium rank or title
with low competition can you explain
that just a little more for me
so
we i think we all have to appreciate our
our place on youtube uh in the sense
that
you as a channel with um a bit of you
you already have a bit of momentum
you're not a complete beginner you know
when you publish a video especially
youtube shorts you're at a point now
where you're getting you know 100 views
200 views so you're already
four or five steps ahead of that
complete beginner when it comes to maybe
gardening content but you also have to
appreciate that there are people on the
youtube journey who have been making
content for
five years ten years they have thousands
of videos so you can choose to either
research that content and see how you
can add something new to that
conversation or that tip of that
strategy
or identify content that's ranking
highly but is now maybe a little bit out
of date in the gardening world i i saw
one of the titles which is really
interesting like how how and when to
water and fertilize
uh your garden during a heat wave which
i think is really
uh really prevalent uh certainly in the
last couple of years
and i feel as if there's more to be
leveraged there
so
yes the search volume may be lower but
you're
you're not trying to get that viral hit
you're not trying to get 50 000 views
with your next video your aim is to get
100 100 views and 150 views and then 200
views and slowly build up that momentum
with a loyal audience that's going to
come back to watch your content because
i feel as if not only you educating
people but people are starting to fall
in love with you as a creator as well
and when you have that as a superpower
then you can start to take your audience
on
all sorts of weird and wonderful
journeys whether it be
um
more gardening or i've seen some videos
where you you talk about clean with me
or you know
ultimately when they get to know your
husband you know you don't have to shove
him off onto another channel you can
start to go on maybe vacations together
and because you have a loyal fan base
they're going to follow you wherever you
go over a period of time of course
okay thank you so much yeah that makes
sense thanks
adrian appreciate you so much thanks so
much for coming on coffee with kennel
today
have a good day all right
we've got
one more rob we're gonna do a quick one
and you're gonna love it we got uh jason
from essential origami coming up here in
just a second but my friends
if you're
if this is your first time on the coffee
with candle show drop that in the
comments down below is this your first
time if you've been on the coffee with
kennel show before let me know
um and uh my name is sean cannell i'm
super fired up
to be here with rob from vidiq hit like
if you've been getting value and
definitely catch the replay where we
talk all about um
keyword research
and how you can leverage that to get
more views on your
channel well hey i'm super pumped hey
half coach thank you so much for
the uh super chat super grateful uh for
that and uh we're gonna welcome
jason
from essential origami super cool
channel i think rob's pulling it up
already jason tell us a little bit about
your channel and uh about uh where
you're streaming from
uh uh for me today morning so good
morning sean and rob it's very exciting
to talk to you guys i've been
uh my youtube channel is about seven
months old so still pretty new
i'm steering from melbourne in australia
so you say just a breakfast time for me
over here
my main question is really uh am i on
the right track i've
i started the channel about a year ago
and then joined the vra and realized
that that channel was more about
entertainment which is very hard to
break into so i've pivoted i've very
much niched down into the an idea called
book folding
which is a craft form where you take
books you cut and fold the pages and it
makes wonderful images on the front if
you
if you spend enough time to to to do
that
um
so i've been uh looking at
uh
any any book folding channel i can find
is pretty much uh dead it's not being
uploaded to
so i think that has a lot of potential
if if i can be
if i can consistently upload upload book
forwarding content
then i think i've got a great chance of
breaking in as one of the main the main
channels in in this area after
some consistent time of course
uh but my main idea is just am i on the
right track i've been trying a whole
bunch of different video ideas i've put
up one recently where
it's just uh the entire book fighting
process real time which goes for about
three and a half hours
which is i don't expect that to be high
in search but i'm also making
uh templates that allow people to make
book art the way that i do i've been
trying to sell those on etsy so the idea
is
if by my etsy template then here's the
entire thing real time you can just zoom
to the part you have trouble with ah
that's where i'm trying to get to
um so i've been doing a bit of that i
realized from a comment that people
thought what i was doing was very
relaxing so i've uploaded one that was
uh asmr and i don't know a thing about
asmr but i just thought it was relaxing
let's try that
i've done some shorts as small as uh 19
seconds where it's just to rapid fire me
flicking through the book can you guess
what this picture is before i get to the
end
so i'm trying lots and lots of different
video ideas just to see what works and
i've got uh you know goals in the future
to make
entire courses uh mate
where i go from start to finish
here's every single possible little
thing you need to know about book art so
i think i've got lots of ideas that
there's plenty of places i can take the
contents just am i
am i on the right track what do you guys
think
are you um
uh
i mean i'll go with my initial thought i
think
the name of the channel is amazing
and i just did the macro keyword
research of origami
um and it's 2 million just for that one
word using the vid iq keyword research
tool which doesn't surprise me
um
to speak to you jason but also to our
greater community sometimes
i think
what's a good thing that we should do
market research and that was in my
10 60 seconds of market research it's
saying is the bigger pool i'm playing in
big enough to support
um is there volume there is there
interest there
and of course oregon and origami is
massive and immediately i saw on youtube
that it's also massive
as far as the book volume thing i think
you found a niche within a niche we call
it double niching or triple or quadruple
niching and sometimes the way that
channels can really grow
is
for example
beauty hair makeup nails
very competitive is it big it's massive
is it big enough to support a lot of
people probably unlimited
um but if you start off covering
everything it might be hard to get
traction and some creators we've coached
they started off by having their first
100 videos 200 videos
be
just nail art and sometimes it might be
bad to pivot away from that but if you
understood the viewer maybe it's like
eventually they start going nail art
then they also do some
uh face makeup etc
punchline being
um are you open
because my gut says
i think you should go deep into the book
folding niche but i wonder if you stay
there if it actually never quite gets
big enough i think the etsy thing's
super smart
but if you also start there 50 videos
100 videos but you're willing to
actually honor the name essential
origami
and and play in
anything origami related to your skills
and passions as well
that your future could be incredibly
bright it's a good start and it also
could scale into
um a niche that's big enough to support
doing this full-time all of the above
would that be a journey you'd be
comfortable with or is there
uh what do you think
yes sir definitely my first couple of
videos were just about origami tutorials
but i decided that was um
uh too broad so i thought i'd focus a
bit more but yeah definitely i can do
some origami related things so
i've got one video where i make a teeny
tiny flower it's about this big so of um
so i'm definitely open to origami uh
related things as well
rob what do you think
yeah i've just been doing a couple of
searches in the background um
specifically on book folding and what it
seems to suggest here is that uh
you just and you are already ranking for
this term
which is both a good a good thing and a
bad thing because it means that all
right
you're ranking for this search term
but you're ranking with views of 100 or
less so ultimately the question is
is anybody searching for this term right
now and i guess that might require a bit
more research
i think also something else to really
consider here you know we haven't talked
about it much um
during during this podcast but
it with the space that you're in you are
judged
very much on the quality of your
thumbnails
uh because when i did a just
a broad search for book folding
you can see like the the wonderful
the art here and how clear the images
are
and i think certainly with crafts and
very visual things
the thumbnail is even more important to
win that click
uh so going back to your channel you may
have to make a tough decision as to
whether you can include yourself in the
thumbnail i mean a lot of these are
shorts i i appreciate that um
but
for example i'm just looking at these
these olympic book folding videos which
i think is a fantastic idea you know you
were jumping on a trend but could i see
the book in a little more detail and
closer up and do we need the explosion
in the background i i know
it's an attempt to be an eye-catching
but i'm just not sure whether that's
going to work long-term but again we're
in the experimental stage and i think
you know you're trying lots of new
unique ideas you know you've already
done these olympic videos you've done a
versus one as well so you're testing out
these new strategies
so
i think you're you're experimenting in
the right ways but you maybe just
haven't quite found that little
pocket of of interest within your topic
just yet
yeah and i would say um
again i that was my total hunch was that
book folding
uh might not just sustain the size of uh
views and impact you want to make i
think it's cool because like
you know rob mentioned you already
dominated so no no problem dominating no
problem potentially being maybe you know
one thing i think we need to know
friends is what is crazy about
youtube is
you're like one netflix
special away
from your niche just absolutely blowing
up so of course chess like origami is a
standard
uh is is a uh incredibly huge thing it's
nothing new
but then the queen's gambit comes out on
netflix and all of a sudden boom chess
channels are blowing up people are
buying every kid wants to you know every
little girl wants to all of a sudden
like all of a sudden all this fire comes
behind something that you're already
positioned for and so again somebody
releases the like hiro dream of sushi
documentary on netflix and one of the
episodes of like a six-part special is
about book folding
now you know your channel uh all of a
sudden just catches fire for some for
the 10 20 30 tutorials you've made in
the past
but it related to i think
where there could be some growth and the
promise of this video and this coffee
with kennel
if we dive into origami
vid iq keyword inspector
i i organize things by very low uh in
terms of the competition
i'm i'm making origami fox max i'm
making origami fox cute and easy mask
you know a lot of people want foxes at
the bottom here there's a a beginner
tutorial desire for origami fox now
maybe you don't want to make a fox and
then of course take that keyword over to
youtube and see maybe what's the intent
is and if you're even passionate about
that but
i'm thinking um paper snake and again
i see origami with two million monthly
searches is a mega niche
so by maybe kind of almost creating by
creating consistent videos well made
that deliver on a promise
to me
it seems that on the other side of again
a lot of hard work a lot of plowing the
field if you will but getting out 50
100.
you know think media just crossed 1 000
uploads
and
that's a crazy yeah crazy crazy journey
and i think
i was maybe sort of single-handedly
responsible for the first 500 but of
course massive credit now we're a team
of creators and so omar and and nolan
and tony
and steph and and kyle and heather like
it's a team that's really helping us
pick up speed but the punchline being
you can't even imagine you probably
can't imagine
the kind of evergreen traffic and one of
the things we just discovered
which is super shocking in fact i really
want to share this
to uh just prove a point and encourage
you jason encourage those that are part
of our think media community and those
that are part of our video ranking
academy students that are watching i
want to show you a unique thing that we
did
in terms of just kind of analyzing the
performance of our channel
one of the things we were curious about
was just what were our best hits over
the last year
uh last 365 days
so that was the first thing we did what
can we learn from these top 10 videos
but then we went in to see more
and we thought okay what can we learn
from beyond the top 10 out of these
videos
but then we went into just a unique way
of
of adding in some distinctions and we
went to
uh
we went to click-through rate what are
the what are the videos at the top
click-through rate
and this just happened to be the path
where we discovered
videos like like this this video from
2015.
so i made a video on the canon 6d a
behind the scenes video
and that's a 6d not mark 2 like the
original 6d right and that video is
getting 11 click-through rate still got
13 000 views i made it six years ago
but then what got really interesting and
this is the one that is going to make
you
spit out your soda water
and talk about what we preach
essentially with video ranking academy
is this video right here
the optica fisheye for the canon vixia
this video came out october 5th
2010.
wow in the last year it got 6105
views my friends
if you want to talk about the dream
of the of youtube as a search engine of
ranking videos on youtube and i
understand like and and here's actually
the thing in the lifetime of this video
it's earned 158 dollars it's grown the
channel by 123 subscribers but in the
last year
this video earned 25
grew think media by six subscribers this
video came out 11
years ago right and like i think what's
even more encouraging is we should watch
it there is no
worse video on youtube than this video i
am the guy who teaches lighting this is
the worst
opening shot
in youtube's history with the backlit
i'm leaning back i don't know what's
happening here
uh i i'm i'm filming on i don't know
what i'm filming on with no crispy team
crispy shaky
pointing at things
like this
this video is horrendous but
what can we learn from it we can learn
that it's it's search based it's about a
specific product rsp review specific
products it's about it's about a
specific fisheye lens for a specific
camcorder
and um
and
some might say oh well
only 6 000 views well 6 000 views 11
years later and so what happens when you
make 10 of those videos if that's all
the only results you got
teaching how to make beginner
origami fox
with blue paper like whatever and you
but you do that 10 100 times you do that
200 times and think media just crossed a
thousand uploads and and and honestly
think media in the early days the first
five years was real sporadic in terms of
uploading there's something about
actually being consistent there's
something about i had to learn a lot of
stuff that we now are helping people go
faster with i mean i wandered in the
desert you know for a while but all that
to say is i think that reveals
the power of of kind of those very
specific maybe low
lower competition specific pain points
that people have in regards to origami
and yes i'm sure there's competition out
there there is there's competition
related to optica fisheye and canon
vixia cameras and and but that video is
also proof
what the heck
you know what i mean like it's no good
hook
not good lighting
not good anything i will admit that uh
sometimes people ask
you know do you ever update your
thumbnails this wasn't the original
thumbnail i did i have gone back
and i've done clearer better thumbnails
because the original one was nowhere
near as good as that and i probably did
that in 2013
three years after it came out but to
kind of turn that back to you jason i
think uh
i think looking at some of the
practical origami that's the bigger
space i'd be playing in
and and uh and then i think it also it
can map to the mindset of maybe some
people who love origami didn't know
about the book stuff i think both are
cool but i think origami is where the
opportunities are
okay so would you recommend i uh
integrate origami with a bit of book out
stuff as well or just move more towards
their origami field
is that i would lean heavier towards
origami
i don't think it's
especially at the stage you're at it's
not offending your audience to do
the book stuff but i would
i would do the uh the book art
10 or 20 of content and i'd be like 80
content on on origami and
saying that we i want to recommend for
everybody
it's double niching is always good the
niche within a niche give you an example
think media we're like best camera for
youtube
back when i started doing that live
streaming wasn't even really a thing or
is very difficult and very expensive and
less common
live streaming is a niche within a niche
if you will because we know you know
what i mean so if in oregon i don't know
what else there is but within origami
maybe there's certain trends or certain
things
with the nice thing is i love the
clarity of origami and your channel name
couldn't i love it like essential
origami is amazing so if it fits
underneath that then absolutely do it
but we've already seen you rank and it
kind of dominates some of the search
terms related to
you know what seems to be a much smaller
niche cool move on to the next one and
that might be doing some stuff related
to foxes you know as we discovered and
definitely leaning into the tools
because that's why we t try it in video
regular academy research before you
press record
so that way your very limited time and
energy can be invested the in the most
strategic video topics possible
okay yeah yeah that makes sense thank
you very much sean
you're welcome jason i appreciate you so
much and uh thanks for coming on
now thank you
thank you
rob i want to thank you for being a part
of coffee with canal before my last word
and closing remarks um but uh thanks
again man you delivered so much value
today so grateful for you
um and i know that
let me know everybody if say uh if
you're thankful for rob drop a comment
in the live chat but also um what's your
takeaway you know we're action takers
here at think media what's an aha moment
do you have a video to make do you have
a video to edit a video to shoot some
keyword research to do
what do you need to do next let us know
and drop some love for uh rob and make
sure if you haven't subscribed
to the vid iq youtube channel rob's over
there dropping just absolute fire all
the time
it's it makes me uncomfortable because
he so quickly
gets to the most strategic ideas in our
niche
uh
i'm like oh there he is talking about
the youtube creator shorts fund or or
the short you know whatever and i'm like
oh you beat me to the but that's why i i
love them and so i'm i'm grateful and i
don't know where our names went rob they
disappeared but uh rob i appreciate you
and uh any final thoughts
yeah thanks for having me on sean it's
always a pleasure and i'm i'm just
inspired by the community you have here
and it may be worth um just replaying
the last hour as
um myself and sean we we encounter these
channels as sometimes complete layman's
we have no idea what the channel's about
we're not very familiar with a topic but
look at
our thought process as as to how we were
trying to understand the fundamentals of
the channel and then try to offer some
suggestions based off of that including
the keyword research aspects of it
100 well rob thank you so much for
coming on appreciate you and uh so much
love is being dropped in the comments
for rob thank you capable wife for
coming on
and uh of course the takeaway is
you gotta just press record
yeah at the end of the day our goal is
to get one percent better with every
upload on youtube and um you know if you
watch this from start to from the
beginning and you're new to youtube the
last two hours of content um it's it's
more it's it's a lot to take in it takes
time to internalize these concepts so i
want to encourage you keep learning but
keep posting
um keep getting one percent better with
every upload and you'll find that um
where you are tomorrow the compound
effect of getting a little bit better at
thumbnails titles a little bit better at
your keyword research a little bit
better on camera or you're doing a
faceless channel a little bit better at
editing whatever it is
um goes a long way
over time and um i want to encourage you
to subscribe to the channel here if you
haven't coffee with kennel uh we do this
bi-weekly so we got the coffee with
kennel show
and then we also have um the youtube
made simple show with heather taurus and
our goal is to alternate those uh every
other week and so definitely um
hopefully
you can catch those we pre-schedule them
and so you can catch those turn on
notifications to the channel here and
then i want to remind you
um
our event growth video live
is uh just a few short days away we have
a two day event uh it happens to our
annual event grow with video live and so
i hope that you can join us for that if
you haven't got your tickets yet
definitely get your tickets at
growwithvideolive.com
until next time keep crushing it keep
smashing it and i can't wait to see you
on the next coffee with kannel or on the
next think media podcast or on the next
upload on our main channel the think
media channel and so until then uh
peace out and remember you gotta just
press record did you know that being a
content creator